Indonesian Marines are pouring into the
area devastated by an earthquake and
tsunami to help with rescues the death
toll climbed overnight to more than 1420
and janeshia still has not evacuated all
of the injured six days after the
disasters Ben Tracy is in hard-hit
helloo with the growing sense of despair
nearly 70,000 people here are now
homeless there's no drinking water
there's no electricity there's nowhere
to buy food and for six days now people
have been waiting for help to arrive the
Indonesian military is finally here with
an army of supplies boxes of water
instant noodles and giant sacks full of
clothes all of it is desperately needed
at the many makeshift homeless camps
that have sprung up all over the
disaster zone this woman named n dong
has been here with her one-year-old
daughter Wuhan for six days a tent is
their only protection from ninety degree
heat they have had a drink water from
the nearby river which is also being
used as a toilet
do you have any idea of how long you'll
be here she says I don't know where to
go I no longer have a home her home was
wiped out by the tsunami triggered by
the 7.5 magnitude earthquake last Friday
the scars on Wu Hans face are from being
rolled by the tsunami waves she says it
is a miracle we found her alive I thank
God she has a new life while we were at
the homeless camp we also saw this man
walking around wearing a sign it
basically says I'm looking for my wife
and I'm looking for my son and he just
told me that he has not seen either of
them since the earthquake happened six
days ago he's holding out hope that they
may still be alive but this is what his
neighborhood now looks like every single
home reduced to piles of charred debris
and we're told that more than 700 homes
were destroyed here during the
earthquake there is now so much debris
here and so little to move it with that
it's hard to imagine how long it's going
to take for them to try to find all the
people who are likely buried here sadly
they expect to find many more
victims this city holds a mass burial
everyday and just dug in second mass
grave for CBS this morning Ben Tracy
Pulu Indonesia Ben Tracy thanks that
cardboard sign just breaks your heart
well mass graves - I mean the numbers
are staggering - are the numbers